terrain rendez vous de notre famille de
la mode africaine est d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ma collection s'appelle hop c'est
l'espoir donc on a essayé d'utiliser des
matériaux qui sont
d'habitude j'étais à la nature en a fait
qu on va beaucoup de place et qu'un peu
partout donc c'est trois places et qu'on
a à faire utiliser en place et qui est
doré et c'est juste vous montrer que
l'on peut utiliser les trucs qui sont
cons jette
en faire d'europe
[Musique]
il on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
crée notre écosystème et on le vit on le
vit librement et on le vit passionnément
et on le vit sans retenue
[Musique]
on
est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les matières afghanes sont mises en
valeur donc l'afrique est mis en valeur
quand je pense que c'est une très très
belle chose mais le défilé était
extraordinaire magnifique